tu es prêt pour ça je vais marcher vers
lui le regarder droit dans les yeux qu'est ce que
tu vas dire ta fille est la meilleure
chose qui me soit arrivée de
toute ma vie ce serait un honneur d'avoir
ta permission  mal
avec vous, vous êtes passé de non répertorié à
officier plus rapidement que quiconque dans l'
histoire de la marine américaine lorsque
nous saisons filles ici, il y a un grand
mystère pour moi, profitez de ces
exercices navals, ils seront probablement
vos derniers
mais je le saurai  contact de surface 8 000
mètres Je veux qu'une chose soit
étudiée à fond Je ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne
idée
dit qu'ils viennent
il est un jour nous les trouvons
sont ils nous trouvent cela a créé une barrière
McCann a semblé la pénétrer qu'est-ce que
tu fais  à nous
il vous amende